hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions if X Y & Z are
positive integers and 3x equals 4 y
equals 5 Z what is the least possible
value of X plus y plus Z this problem is
adapted from a GRE test question where
you have an average of two minutes per
question this is an American exam so
I'll mentioned to my viewers in France
that positive integers means strictly
positive pause the video if you'd like
to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
so how do we solve this problem notice
that three x equals 4 y equals 5 C will
equal some integer number n this number
n will have to be a multiple of 3 4 & 5
the smallest value of n will be the
least common multiple of 3 4 & 5 we take
the highest power of each prime factor
and multiplied them together to get the
least common multiple of 60 we then need
to calculate the values of XY and Z and
we can readily do that knowing that n is
equal to 60 we get X is equal to 20 Y is
equal to 15 and Z is equal to 12 we then
need to calculate the sum which is X
plus y plus C and that'll be 47 and
that's the answer so some of you this
problem will be easy and I hope that's
the case because on a tests like the GRE
you have to solve these problems very
quickly and you have to understand the
technique so I hope this video helps
some people who didn't know this
technique thanks for watching and for
making mind your decisions one of the
best channels on YouTube thanks for
watching and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]